how similar are French and Portuguese
that's the question that we're going to
answer in this video and to be 100%
clear I'm talking about languages not
nationalities every time I make a
language comparison video like this
there are some people who just read the
title and without even watching the
video leave comments like don't compare
us with those people they're completely
different from us what I'm talking about
languages as most of you know French and
Portuguese are both romance languages
part of the italic branch of the wider
Indo-European language family like all
romance languages French and Portuguese
both developed from varieties of Vulgar
Latin the colloquial varieties of Latin
spoken in various areas of the Roman
Empire because of their common origin
they are very similar languages in
general ways but because they developed
independently from each other they have
many differences in the details of their
pronunciation systems vocabulary and
grammar are French and Portuguese
mutually intelligible in other words can
their speakers understand understand
each other no they generally can't
understand each other in speech this is
in large part due to their different
pronunciation in writing they're
somewhat more mutually intelligible but
not completely let's hear a short sample
of either language first
[Music]
French
and now
Port the level of intelligibility and
speech depends partly on the variety of
Portuguese since European Portuguese and
Brazilian Portuguese are pronounced
rather differently the samples in this
video will be mainly from Brazilian
Portuguese the speaker is from Rio de
Janeiro or hi Janeiro vocabulary French
and Portuguese have 75% lexical
similarity meaning that 75% of either
language's words have cognates
equivalent words of the same origin in
the other language for comparison French
and Italian have 89% mexical similarity
and so do Portuguese and Spanish let's
look at some common words in either
language some are the same or almost the
same in writing and just differ somewhat
in pronunciation for example the words
meaning Central in French Central and in
Portuguese Central the words for animal
in French animal and in Portuguese
animal the words for Hospital
opal the words meaning popular
popular in general though cognate words
resemble each other somewhat but have
fairly different forms and spelling take
the simple sentence meaning I love you
in French it's in
Portuguese or the subject pronouns and
are cognates both from Vulgar Latin AO
the object pronoun T is the same in
either language though the Portuguese
pronunciation varies depending on the
accent in Brazilian Portuguese it's
pronounced Chi M and um are also
cognates the first person present tense
form of and respectively as is the case
with most cognates when you know they're
cognates you can easily see the
similarity between them but they have
different forms some other words the
words for cat French and
Portuguese from
latinus the words for friend French and
Portuguese amig both from Latin amus my
friend has a cat in
French word for word it's my friend has
a cat and in
Portuguese word for word my friend has a
cat the verbs meaning to see in French
and in
Portuguese both from
Latin the words for all or everything
French and
Portuguese both from Latin to I want to
see everything in Paris in
French
word for word I want everything see at
Paris in
Portuguese word for word I want see
everything in Paris also notice that the
word for want a very useful and common
word in any language is different in
French and in
Portuguese also note the difference in
word order in French the direct object
comes before the second verb while in
Portuguese it comes after the second
verb some words are entirely different
we'll see some examples in a minute but
first a few words about French and
Portuguese courses that I think you
should check out if you're excited to
learn French or Portuguese I highly
recommend you check out the courses
French uncovered and Portuguese
uncovered from the company story
learning the uncovered series was
created by Olie Richards a major figure
in the language learning community whose
approach to language learning is based
on using stories you may have seen some
of his bestselling books at your local
Bookshop or on Amazon including his
books on French and Brazilian Portuguese
his uncovered courses are based on the
same philosophy of story learning but
they're much more intensive and are
designed to take you from a beginner
level up to the B1 level lower
intermediate so that you can genuinely
communicate at a basic level with French
speakers and Brazilian Portuguese
speakers the courses consist of 20
chapters of a story with each chapter
containing not only a core reading and
listening lesson but also additional
video lessons and exercises that build
on the core materal material if you're
tired of boring apps and grammar-based
translation I recommend you try out the
story learning approach with French
uncovered and Portuguese uncovered if
you click my link in the description you
can try it free for 7 days and if you
upgrade to a paid course Lang Focus gets
a small commission that helps support
this channel so it's win-win it's great
for you and it's great for Lang focus by
the way French and Portuguese aren't the
only languages in the uncovered series
they have courses for Spanish Turkish
German Japanese Chinese and others I'll
put a link to this page with all of
their courses in the description below
and now back to the main video some
words are entirely different the words
for thank you French mer and
Portuguese or depending on the gender of
the speaker these both come from Latin
but different words mer comes from Latin
medic which means wage or reward it
began to be used with the meaning of a
favor then the expression Mery began to
be used to give thanks for a great favor
that someone had done for you the
Portuguese word oblig comes from Latin
obligat this means obliged and is like
saying I am obliged or I'm indebted to
you just like in somewhat old-fashioned
English you could say I'm much obliged
to express thanks in most of the cases
when vocabulary differs between French
and Portuguese both words still come
from
Latin meaning
also meaning
more meaning
very meaning
city meaning
house meaning table there are also false
Friends words that appear deceptively
similar but actually have different
meanings for example the French word
means to hear while the Portuguese word
means to
understand this French sentence means I
heard the announce an m word for word
it's I have heard the
announcement this Portuguese sentence
means I understood the announcement word
for word I I understood the announcement
we'll talk about the different verb
tenses later the French word means sober
and comes from
latinus the Portuguese word means on or
over or about and comes from Latin super
the French word means late while the
Portuguese word word means both late and
afternoon the French word for afternoon
is notice the pronunciation of this
French word again compare that to the
Portuguese word
again something that sets French apart
from other major romance languages
including Portuguese is its abundance of
silent letters at the end of words some
more examples the word for three
French
Portuguese and the word for Rice French
Portuguese
in French this happens when the
consonant is at the end of the word and
because Portuguese words have a much
greater tendency to end in a vowel than
French words French words can often
sound quite truncated compared to their
Portuguese equivalents the words for
when in French in
Portuguese the words for
time the words for
white silent consonants might be the
main thing that sets French
pronunciation apart from that of other
romance languages something else sets
Portuguese pronunciation apart
especially European Portuguese it has a
strong tendency for vowels to be reduced
devoiced or dropped in unstressed
syllables let's take the name of the
country Portugal in French portug and in
Portuguese portug the first vowel is
reduced to the word for people or folks
in French and in Portuguese jint
unstressed a frequently becomes or is Dr
dropped the words for Market in
French and in
Portuguese but to be clear in Brazilian
accents vowels are not reduced as much
as they are in European Portuguese or
are reduced differently because of this
speakers of other romance languages
often say they have a much easier time
understanding Brazilian Portuguese than
European Portuguese this is the point in
the video when speakers of European
Portuguese start a riot in the
comments notice that in Brazilian
Portuguese l is pronounced w at the end
of a
syllable notice that in Brazilian
Portuguese when a is unstressed it's
commonly reduced to e nasal vowels
people often notice that French and
Portuguese are pronounced quite
differently from other romance languages
in particular their abundance of nasal
vowels for example the French word
meaning good and the Portuguese word
boom both have nasalized vowel sounds in
both Lang languages the nasal consonants
M and N in a syllable Koda are no longer
pronounced instead they nasalized the
preceding vowel the words for garden
French and
Portuguese the words for train
Portuguese the words for sound French
and
Portuguese but note that the nasal
vowels are different in either language
French has three or four nasal vowels
Portuguese has five nasal vowels along
with five or six nasal diff thongs which
French doesn't have notice that the same
nasal vowel can be represented by
different spellings in either language
the Portuguese alphabet includes some
characters that represent nasal vowels
on their own without M or n but the
French alphabet doesn't for example the
French wordo meaning magnet the
Portuguese word which was borrowed from
French takes this form IM you can see
that this vowel with a diacritic is used
instead of a an and because in French
the final T is silent it's not written
in the lone word in Portuguese another
example
French meaning lesson the Portuguese
cognate is in Old Galician Portuguese it
was spelled like this more similar to
the French word which shows that this
vowel may not have become nasalized yet
but then it became written like this
with a nasalized o then the final nasal
vowel became diiz oh you can frequently
see this in corresponding French and
Portuguese word endings
the words for region French and
Portuguese the words for
reason also in most cases the ending IO
n in French also corresponds with this
Portuguese dong the words for station
St the words for
impression this nasal dong is an
extremely common ending in Portuguese
because it comes from the merging of
three different word endings
particularly in nouns the endings don't
always correspond between French and
Portuguese cognates but sometimes they
do the words for bread french and
Portuguese which used to be pun the
words for hand French and
Portuguese which used to be Mano but
some Portuguese words still end in o
these days pronounced Anu take the words
for human in French and in
Portuguese this is particularly the case
with ad Ives and words like this that
can be used as either a noun or an
adjective one might assume that the
abundance of nasal vowels in both French
and Portuguese indicates some common
history that they don't share with the
other romance languages but that's not
really the case the nasal vowels arose
independantly from each other in
addition to an abundance of nasal vowels
another similarity between French and
Portuguese is that they both have a
guttural r sound in French the r sound
used to be an alv Trill but now the voed
juular fricative
is used in Parisian and standard French
which is voiceless in some
contexts there's no Trill anymore in
Portuguese there used to be both an alv
Trill and an alv tap but the trill has
been replaced by the voice juular
frickative in European Portuguese and by
or H in Brazilian Portuguese depending
on the regional accent the words for
terrible in French ter and in
Portuguese the word for war in
French and in
Portuguese apparently both come from old
Germanic the word for iron
is but unlike French Portuguese also
retains the alv tap in some environments
though this depends on the accent the
word for book in
French in
Portuguese which actually means free not
book the Portuguese word for book is the
French word for free is Li this is an
example of false friends there's a lot
of variety in Portuguese Ric sounds
meaning R sounds but the main point here
is that in both French and Portuguese
the trillar has been replaced by
guttural frickative
sounds grammar in general French and
Portuguese have very similar grammar as
romance languages in general do but
there are a handful of notable
differences the most notable difference
is probably that Portuguese is pro drop
while French isn't in other words in
Portuguese the subject pronoun is
usually not necessary unless you're
emphasizing it while in French the
subject pronoun can't be dropped we can
see that in these sentences meaning I
work at a bookstore in Portuguese you
can say this with the
pronoun or
without word for word I I work in a
feminine bookstore in French the pronoun
is
required I I work in a feminine
bookstore
another difference in grammar is that in
Portuguese object pronouns can come
after the verb but not in French except
in the imperative for example these
sentences mean we gave him the keys in
Portuguese word for word we gave to him
the plural keys in
French word for word we to him have
given the plural Keys notice that in
Portuguese the indirect object pronoun
comes after the verb while in French it
comes before it though I should note
that this Portuguese sentence is a
formal written sentence in speech at
least in Brazilian speech this sentence
would be more
natural and more informally this
sentence notice that the Portuguese and
French sentences use different verb
tenses the Portuguese sentence uses the
simple past while the French sentence
uses the present perfect
or in French it consists of an auxiliary
verb in this case a meaning have plus
the past
participle both tenses exist in both
languages but are used a little
differently in French the simple past
tense is not really used in speech
anymore and has limited literary use the
present perfect is the normal way of
expressing the simple past tense in
Portuguese the simple past is the usual
way the present perfect tense normally
has a present perfect progressive
meaning in
Portuguese where for word we we have to
him given the keys this sentence would
mean we've been giving him the keys
notice that while in the
French the object pronoun comes before
the auxiliary verb in Portuguese it is
suffix to the end of the auxiliary verb
let's also look at some of the
vocabulary in these sentences for a
moment French and Portuguese sh appear
quite different but they're actually
cognates they both come from the Latin
word clavis meaning key French is the
past participle of the verb Don which
means to give it comes from
Latin which means to give or bestow like
to present something special to someone
Portuguese is the past participle of the
verb which means to give it comes from
the Latin verb D which means to give in
a more basic way so again we see two
different words in either language that
are both from Latin and the most
important thing to note here is that the
auxiliary verb is different from the
present perfect in Portuguese it's which
means to have and comes from
Latin meaning to physically have
something in your possession in French
it's which also has the meaning to have
but comes from a different Latin
verb which means to have something in
the sense of owning it again two
different words but both are from Latin
in French the present perfect and other
compound perfect tenses have one of two
possible auxiliary verbs like in this
case or the verb meaning to be it's used
as the auxiliary verb for a limited
number of intransitive verbs in
particular those related to movement but
in Portuguese the auxiliary verb is
always so in French we have this
sentence this means I went out every day
word for word it's I I am gone out all
the plural days and in Portuguese we
have this
sentence this means I've been going out
every day word for word it's I I have
gone out all the plural days note that
the
verbs and both mean to go out but
developed from different verbs in
Latin is the first person singular
present tense form
of in French there's only one verb
meaning to be but in Portuguese there
are
two which generally means to be for
temporary conditions and which generally
means to be for permanent conditions for
example in Portuguese this means I'm
nervous word for word it's I I am
temporary
nervous this sentence means I'm a
nervous person meaning that it's part of
my personality word for word it's I I am
permanent a person nervous in French
both sentences use the same
verb I'm nervous word for word I I am
nervous and this sentence means I'm a
nervous
person word for word it's I I am a
person nervous one other difference
between verbs in French and Portuguese
is that French doesn't really have a
verb construction that expresses the
present continuous the way Portuguese
does here's a Portuguese sentence
meaning I'm eating dinner right
now word for word I am eating dinner now
the present continuous is expressed with
the verb meaning to be in the temporary
sense plus the Jaren form of the verb in
this case the verb which means to have
dinner it used to mean to have lunch and
it developed from the Latin
verb which meant to have breakfast
here's the French sentence meaning I'm
eating dinner right
now I I am in the middle of eat dinner
now or
just word for word it's I eat dinner now
using the
phrase emphasizes that the action is in
progress right now kind of like in the
middle of but you could just use the
simple present tense instead throughout
this video you've probably observed that
French and Portuguese are quite similar
in general ways sharing similar sentence
structure and a lot of similar
vocabulary of common origin but I'm sure
you also observed all the little
differences I mentioned as well as a lot
of other little differences in
pronunciation how cognate words are
formed not to mention that a lot of
words are just different a lot of the
time all those little differences add up
French and Portuguese definitely seem
more different than French and Italian
or Portuguese and Spanish if you're a
native speaker of French or Portuguese
how well are you able to understand the
other language either in speech or in
writing and to other people what's your
impression of how close French and
Portuguese are to each other and once
again it's time to give a shout out to
all of the Lang focused patreon
supporters especially the top tier
patrons whose names appear right here on
the screen they deserve a special thank
you for continuing to help make this
channel possible if you liked this video
and are interested in more check out my
playlist on romance languages you'll
find more comparisons like this as well
as language profiles on various
individual
languages